so what are the stages of grief and how
on earth might they be helpful to us in
this time and that's what I'd like to
unpack today my name is Brett sulfur
pastor the table Church in sexy Texas
and welcome to Table Talk
where each week I pack ideas and
insights at the intersection of
Christian theology and culture to help
you become a more thoughtful calm and
just a wonderful human being all right
so what are these stages of grief well
in 1969 Elisabeth kubler-ross wrote her
groundbreaking book on death and dying
and there she outlined what she referred
to as the five stages of grief they are
denial anger bargaining depression and
acceptance and her big idea is that the
experience of grief is often expressed
via these emotions Vasili those first
four now one common misconception is
that these are linear stages that you go
through one by one in other words when
we experience some sort of loss or
suffering then you know first we're in
denial and then we get to anger because
you know that stage two and then on to
stage three bargaining but no know as
human beings the process is much more
messy than this
sometimes we might start with a sense of
depression and then we might get angry
and then we might start acting in denial
and then back to anger so it's it's not
a like a linear neat and tidy process
however I don't think that means that
Ross's insight doesn't have merit
because what she does help us name so
powerfully is is that the crazy
emotional roller coaster that we are on
sometimes basically means that we are
grieving in other words our anger might
actually be a response to grieve not the
or the person we think it's about or our
depression just might be grief it might
be our body's way of responding to
something that is overwhelming us now
for context I'm shooting this video on
April 9th 2020 so we're about a month or
so into the quarantine process of the
corona virus pandemic that has washed
over our world like a tsunami and so I
don't think it's a stretch to suggest
that many of you watching this video
have been moving through these stages
whether you realize it or not personally
I feel that I cycle through each of
these or like one of them roughly every
two to three days or so so for example I
would be experiencing waves of anger for
three days and then I'd be in denial for
three days like virus
what virus and then into a place of
struggling with discouragement and mild
depression and so on and so I suspect
I'm not through processing all of this
and if you're anything like me then you
probably aren't over it either okay so
what should we do well like I think the
big question is you know how do we
process this in a spiritually and
emotionally healthy way
so let me go ahead and give you three
steps step number one is give it a name
name out loud what you're feeling both
to yourself and to a trusted friend or
family member for example if you're
angry then name that like not loud say
you know I think I'm really feeling
angry right now or I just I feel really
down and depressed and then say I guess
it's simply part of my grieving process
this this brings clarity and it helps
you not create the double wound of
getting upset like either at yourself
you know by saying I shouldn't even feel
this way or upset at others I'm feeling
this way because of you instead in a
calm and clear way you're able to name
your grief and then bring in others to
help you carry that burden right that's
first second give it to Christ one of
the beautiful aspects of Christian faith
is that Jesus is known as Immanuel which
means God with us and the one who is God
with us did not live some sort of comfy
life of privilege but rather he
experienced death even death on a cross
god knows what it is to suffer just
think of the Garden of Gethsemane
Jesus as the fully human one knows what
it is to greet knows what it is to feel
anger even to bargain remember when he
said father if there's any way let this
cup pass from me but he knew and yet he
entered into it he he hung in solidarity
with all of the grieving people of the
world so when we give it to Christ
there's a sense in which we are saying
lord please hold this for me
it's overwhelming me I need you to carry
it you could do this via journaling or
simply through just a spoken prayer but
however you do it there's something
really emotionally releasing about
giving it to God third give it time even
after giving it a name and giving it to
Christ it's likely you'll you'll find
like some relief but it's not as though
your suffering and grief will just
simply vanish like the mist that's why
you must give it time you must accept
what you're feeling is recognize that it
may be with you for quite some time like
probably a day more likely a week
probably even longer and that's not
something we need to you know fight I
don't fight it don't get all worked up
about it and certainly don't make
drastic life-altering decisions and
response to it because it's it's it's an
emotion it will pass often we're very
impatient with our feelings with our
grief we want it to change and we want
to change now but paradoxically by by
accepting what you're feeling and
talking to others about it and then
giving it to Christ and giving it time
you'll actually speed
the healing process that's all for today
if you enjoyed this video and you think
others would benefit from it please
click the like and share buttons also if
you'd like to ensure you don't miss
future episodes go ahead and subscribe
to my youtube channel or my podcast most
anywhere podcasts are offered by
searching Brett Tilford Tabletalk grace
and peace